it was dark in New York for like two
days after that flood you were that you
were there like yeah the Lower East Side
was that we had no power for like what
two weeks something like that yeah maybe
two days of really dark like weird
yeah and and like the flood damage
destroyed windows and knocked over bus
stand and that's just a hurricane and
then you had um the rockaways were just
yeah that's where I lived I lived in Far
Rockaway well after actually I moved
there right after the right after the
damage it was wrecked the whole
Coastline was wrecked and uh I went I
actually took the train down to uh
document the relief work that was going
on and it was crazy to see like the the
the uh the boardwalks like ripped up
it's just houses destroyed when the
lights go out in a city man it is
another place it's not home it's dark
and cold and dangerous you do
not want to be in a city in the dark it
is terrifying hard pass and that's after
like two days of it being dark I don't
know after two weeks of it being dark
you're gonna see everything lit on fire